or astronauts are getting ready to dock
at the International Space Station after
their SpaceX rocket lifted off last
night the Axiom 2 flight is the second
ever private mission to the orbiting lab
now it's also the first mission in 38
years for Saudi Arabia's Space Program
Mark Strassman has more on the launch
Sunday's liftoff Picture Perfect only
the second time a commercial Mission has
launched for the International Space
Station a great View
three space rookies and their Commander
a former NASA Pioneer this is the
Japanese module what's your head as we
come in once again Peggy Whitson is
shooting High heading back to space at
age 63. it was a home away from home for
me and I really want to experience it
again and let it engulf me this time
commanding a commercial mission to the
space station here comes Woodson for a
final farewells final hugs as she
departs the space station America's most
experienced astronaut last left the ISS
in 2017. she took three trips there as a
NASA astronaut totaling a record
665 days in space with 10 spacewalks
another record for women could you have
ever imagined you'd have the chance to
go back the realistic part of Peggy said
no you're not likely to be able to
pinching yourself uh every day every day
it is so exciting her Axiom 2 crew
includes two Saudi government astronauts
including the first Saudi woman in space
and John schoffner a 67 year old
Knoxville entrepreneur pilot and
lifelong Adventurer is it what you
expected no it never is Whitson and
schoffner walked us through the ISS
training mock-up at the Johnson Space
Center in Houston then talked about his
first trip to space when did the space
bug first bite you my earliest
Recollections 1963 and it never left we
even had a young astronauts Club when I
was eight years old
and John was the leader I was a
commander
well of two people
Axiom 2's crew will fly aboard a SpaceX
crew dragon to the ISS total time aboard
eight days price tag unknown but
shoffner is paying his own way
presumably in the millions but Whitson
and schoffner agree this is more than a
rich guy's space junket there has always
been an astronaut in me waiting to get
out I'm here to perform she sets high
expectations well high expectations are
her entry level okay
this new space era is redefining the
right stuff you do need that sense of I
want to explore I want to try something
new it's helpful to have an objective I
think that will build the strongest
group of people in space
This Crew will do a lot more than take
selfies and look down on Earth they'll
perform more than 20 science experiments
including microgravity's effect on stem
cell research and Nate if I was going to
space I'd want Peggy Whitson as my
commander no doubt about it mark thank
you